and I open it up in the smell
that comes out of 75 different people's
rags it's kind of like a cross
between like when ghostbusters cross
streams and an Indiana Jones when they
open up the Ark of the Covenant and all
the Germans
[Music]
host Ari Shaffir tonight all the stories
are about disasters please welcome this
next comic the host of the punch on
sports podcast mr. Shapiro remind ok
this is a quick story about how I
understood the lyrics to a song for the
first time I last year I went to China
they told me two things I went for
comedy so they told me two things before
I went they gave me two rules first role
they said no bring drugs in of any kind
because they said it's punishable by
death
yeah like how much week I bring and
they're like Ari none and I was like
counteroffer son Eric don't do it I'm
not bringing pot cookies to the plane
you can't stop me and I did and then we
landed in Shanghai like to pop cookies
left over so I just downed them and had
a great first eight hours and shining on
it was wonderful usually they don't tell
you it's not punishable by death to
traffic drugs is punishable by death but
if they just catch you with them there
it's very illegal it's still very
illegal they'll kick you out of the
country that's what they'll do but I
thought about it and it turns out that I
don't live in China so let's do it
so fun three weeks in China for comedy
every once in a while every once in a
while comedy really pays off I got to do
is live in poverty for nine years then
you get your free trip to China
the cool thing is it's so illegal
marijuana and all drugs there especially
we once you do find weed there and I did
find weight because I'm a pothead
that's what pot heads do we find weed
when you do find weed the cops in China
do not know what marijuana smells like
yeah it's just not around so this
comedian in Beijing showed me goes dude
you can smoke pot right in front of them
a blue pot smoke right at a cop I'm like
are you out of your mind because he just
thinks you're smoking tobacco for poor
people
he's never smelled that smell before the
only way they can catch it literally the
only way they can catch you is if you
learn the Mandarin words for officer
we're smoking marijuana and my advice is
just don't learn those words they're not
going to help you
the other rule that gave me is they said
they said no making fun of the Chinese
government no making any jokes about
Chinese government and I was like I mean
just about Chinese go right him get
over yourself Chinese government
nobody's talking about what I've done
comedy in Los Angeles New York London in
Toronto and I've never heard a single
comedian do any jokes with a Chinese
government
because it's way too self-absorbed here
was the cool thing about China well
everything here was a terrible thing at
about all of Asia it's the toilet
situation yeah so you know the seats to
go up and down for men and women like
that seat so they don't have that seat
and then they also they don't have the
whole toilet they don't have any of it
have toilets they don't believe it or
something
they just got holes in the ground um
literally it's like a regular bathroom
floor with tiles and everything and then
we're the toilet should be is just this
hole and you're supposed to go over it
like a college basketball coach and just
with a scrub it's a squat and into
this hole and they don't tell you at all
they don't tell you about any of it
they just SPECT you to know so I'm by
the way in the hotels and selling of
regular toilets it's just in the rural
parts so I was having a good time went
to the Great Wall of China I went to I
went to visit the Imperial Palace that
was cool no wait that's Star Wars
Imperial Palace yeah that's for sure
Star Wars yeah what is the Forbidden
City that's what it is whatever I lived
and so I went there and I was walking
around having a good time and I got this
important phone call from my friend
diarrhea and that's when I really
started to hate China because this
toilet situation I run to the bathroom
I'm just sprint to find the bathroom I
first opened the door I'm telling you
right now when you open up a stall door
and there's no toilet in there your mind
can't even wrap its head around what's
happening
it's like some sort of optical illusion
you know it's like which line is longer
look I know top one like no same size
measure again regular bathroom
or tiles and then just hole it
let's say a union guy was coming to
install a toilet and then it was like a
lunch time and they just left
they forgot to get back to it I burst
open the door and I was like what oh
this one must be under repair this is no
toilet that's the one thing you look for
in a toilet it's the toilet that's 95
percent of the experience is the actual
toilet and I went to the next one I was
like this one are they all under repair
am I just missing the sign and then I
remember like oh they told me about
these these squat toilets
that's what you're supposed to do and I
realize right then I was like you know
what I'm not doing this I was born in
America and I'll die in America and
Americans sit down and we that's
our thing when they say USA number one
they're talking about number two we're
number one in number two and I was like
I'm gone so I left I walked out and I
got like two steps away and then
diarrhea was like of course you're doing
it you it gives you a break sometimes
diarrhea
you know diarrhea in the hiccups oh you
think they're gone for a minute but
they're ain't gone
we're like I gotta so better but no
let me in okay no no my hands of it so I
go back into this into this stall I
close the door
side note by the way there's a trash can
in there and all these don't
look in the trash can because they don't
flush the toilet paper they throw it
away
yeah and so they have this trash can you
know that the little office trash cans
it like spin the top spins you know
where it goes like then you can like hit
it down and it like I always try to hit
it just enough so it pops back up and
like go like it's like a ride at Six
Flags work you know and I open it up in
the smell that comes out of 75
different people's rags it's kind
of like a cross between like when
ghostbusters cross streams and uh an
indiana jones when the open of the Ark
of the Covenant and all the Germans look
that's just smell that comes out of this
thing so I go into this muck install I
close the door I'm looking at this hole
here's my first question how far do you
take your pants down
I'd done it and I don't know what the
answer is I have no idea my first
thought was like take them down to your
ankles because that's how I normally do
it but then you can't do that because
here's a deal I went down I pick them
out of my ankles and then I like lined
it up and I like hold on a second like
my asshole is directly above my pants
how am I not going to into my pants
unless a heavy gust of wind comes by I'm
for sure gonna into my pants and by
the way I thought about it and I
realized that into your pants
is actually a lot worse than in
your pants you think they'd be the same
thing right
they're not the same thing into
your pants is a holocaust compared to
in your pants because if you
in your pants and let's be honest a
lot of us have done that am I not wrong
like I mean like after ninth grade
it happens whatever you're drinking and
you sneeze that's not your fault
that's just destiny that's just destiny
what are you doing that happens I know
what I do I go home I go home cuz I'm a
grown man I've my pants and I can't
be out with my people just can't I can't
be on the people that my pants I
think about it usually for a second like
how much is in there you know it
goes to my head and then I realize it
doesn't matter it does not matter
it could be a shart and it could be an
unloading either way I'm a grown-up and
I've my pants and I can't be out
with other people and I know what I'm
doing every line in the movie okay guys
that's still funny huh - I'll see you
guys later
like what were you going you want to see
the movie my god I want to see anymore
you tell me how it was just
slowly just real slowly walk away you
don't want to jostle at all you know I
mean just even steps it's just gonna be
a little bit warmer than it was before
yeah that's if you in your pants
but if you into your pants well
then you got to not have those pants on
and then you got to work up the courage
the suicide like courage put the dirty
diaper back on yourself and you know
it's gonna screw SH in there like you're
making a mold for a retainer so anyway
it's not down to your ankles I don't
think and by the way the one time you
want handicap bars - hold on - I don't
have handicap bars they make me
Zen about it and just go
use your core so I don't know what the
answer is they don't help you in any way
by the way there's no diagram
help along the way
everything has a diagram on it a hand
dryer in a bathroom a big machine
that's right next to the sink with one
button right in the middle like now
you'll never figure this out so they put
a little cartoon on it of somebody
pushing the button and then somebody
else drawing their hands or taking the
bacon that's a hand dryer Chinese
squat toilet now figure it out it's
intuitive so I have no idea I didn't
know what to do so here's what I did I
don't know this is right or wrong but I
took my shirt off and you know the hook
that's on a door the bathroom cells I
just sort of hooked it on there
I feel like a right now yeah I
don't know if that's the right answer or
not but that's what I did it seemed to
work it seemed to work I mean I
that way so I felt good too when I did
it I was like yeah look like a real
Chinese person and I finished and it
feels great when you like this by
the way it's all it clears you out from
the neck all the way down it's like
you're a new man have you ever done it
it feels wonderful I do it now when I
get home I'll stand on my toilet seat
and then I'll squat over just
for old times sake like a POWs got to
sleep underneath the bed once in a while
and I did it I felt great I felt
wonderful I was very careful not let my
balls touch the surface of the thing
because I have very long balls and
they'll occasionally touch the water
level of a toilet and if there's one
place I want my balls to never touch its
the inside of a Chinese squat
toilet so anyway I finished I was like
yeah I did it I got up to wipe and
that's when I found out that they don't
offer toilet paper in China
yeah they don't believe in it I think
their theory is you're the one
you clean it up and that's not wrong
it's not even that it's wrong I'm just
saying you should warn people you should
let people know like everyone who lands
at the airport with a round eye there's
you get my pamphlet and be like here
you're gonna have some problems
figure it out stand on my what am I
gonna do well anyway here's the deal
five days before I landed in Shanghai
first place I got to got there in the
morning I got to a club the first place
I performed this bar and the club owner
was like the bar owner was like um I
just got here today and I was like yeah
and he goes oh and he gave me this
packet of tissue paper you know this
little travel Kleenex packs and it gave
me one of those and he goes here you'll
need this it was like Gandalf that come
over here something you know and I was
like what will I need it for he just
goes you'll know and but he was right
though he was right I was standing there
that toilet at the Forbidden
City you know it's so excited here's the
problem though they don't give you
unlimited tissue paper in one of those
things that give you six they give you
six pieces of tissue paper with six you
can't be an American anymore it can't be
like a four - time I love to waste most
resources in the world you will owe us
earth not with six for six you got a
budget
you got to make every one count gonna
start like way from the bottom and go
all the way up to about here fold go
back start from the bottom now we're
here I kept doing that start from the
bottom now here start from the bottom
now here and that's when I realized what
that Drake song was all about
[Music]